today I'll stick to football we are back
in office and oh my gosh we were doing a
free agency preview before things kick
off in about two weeks
coming off the combine the tampering
period has unofficially begun so we are
gonna break it down Connor but before we
get into that a little bit of an
announcement we got to start the show
with some sad news today obviously most
you probably saw that Monday night a
tornado hit Nashville hit downtown
Nashville and just went ten miles east
of there because of that and because of
some concerns regarding travel due to
the spread of the corona virus right now
we are actually cancelling our event at
hunting fire barbeque so that was gonna
be Saturday the 14th of March just want
to let everyone know that is canceled
obviously Nashville is one of our
favorite places the entire world so just
want to say from all of us here at stick
to football all right our thoughts and
prayers are with you guys
however we can help we'll be doing it
you know Melo and I live in a town that
was tore apart by a tornado several
years back so so we definitely can
sympathize with what you guys are going
through yeah without a doubt it's it's a
shame what not only what happened in
Nashville obviously you know but the
event being canceled a lot of people get
excited for but we're just thinking
about how you know they're gonna rebuild
there and for the people that are hurt
or lost their lives were thinking of
that as well so just wanted to get that
off the top as we begin our show today
yeah and it is gonna be a loaded show
like I said a huge free-agency preview
we're gonna go position by position not
just break down the players but tell you
some of the things we're hearing about
fits some of the best fits even if it's
not a rumor just say hey this guy makes
a lot of sense here so it is gonna be an
informative show today and a lot of you
who are draft fans wait what it's six
weeks before the draft why you guys to
my free agency free agency will inform
the draft for us in whatever way so we
got it we got to get through free agency
first but Connor we are officially home
from the combine and there's still some
lingering things to talk about
especially because when the line backers
ran on Sunday or excuse me on Saturday
we were recording our event the DB's ran
on Sunday we were on our ways home
Patrick Queen and Kenneth Murray I
talked to both guys over the weekend
both said they're doing well Kenneth
Murray even said listen
I stayed tonight hung out and watch the
rest of the drills I'm okay like he got
an MRI he's good it she's been called a
strain and I know both players are
hoping they're able to go out there pro
day so two guys who it's unfortunate
because I thought they both ran really
well in that first 40 getting in there
four fives but I'll tell you they were
actually upset about those times and
something I want to get into off of this
a lot of agents and trainers and players
are very upset coming out of this year's
combine because of the injuries because
the timing but at least for right now
two of the best players in that draft it
and we saw Jeff Okuda take a nasty fall
and hit his head on the turf yeah so I
guess you could say three of our
favorite players on defense had to deal
with something a little extra at the
combine yeah it felt like that
throughout the entire weekend guys were
just pulling up guys were getting banged
up and I think honestly Matt a lot of it
was probably precautionary because you
don't want to take the risk of getting
significantly hurt there because as much
as you and I and all the fans of the NFL
Draft and the NFL for the purpose of
ratings love the NFL Combine they love
the workouts they see they love the
drills where they get to record actual
testing numbers what matters most to a
lot of these players is not only the
individual workouts and time they get
with teams but also their pro day where
they can be in a controlled environment
where Scouts that honestly have been
trailing them hoping to draft them will
be there any way to record their own
time so I think the most important thing
is where you have the best chance to
succeed is your pro day and individual
workouts and that's where you get the
best face time with teams that are
interested in taking you and I think we
saw a lot of players rightfully and
agents as well protect themselves at the
combine this year more than usual and
that's you know before the combine
started it was something I tweeted and
we've talked about it a lot throughout
the week I'm not trying to be
self-serving I'm just letting people
know they're like there was concern
before the combine even started teams
were excuse me not teams agents and
trainers were worried about third guys
because there is the unknown and this is
exactly what we were talking about there
was a lot of pushback on Twitter for
people saying oh like they're how hard
is it to now run at four o'clock instead
of at 8 a.m. it's a lot different and we
saw that I you can look at the combine
results even and that's something I've
been doing a lot over the weekend just
trying to up
my database with all the times and all
the numbers it is shocking how many
people did not perform especially the
skill players like look at the wide
receivers or look at the DBS how many
guys only did one or two things it's
shocking how many players there were
this year and that just goes to the
point and I'm not trying to piss off the
NFL do a good enough job of that without
not digging my own home but this is a
problem and it's a problem not only from
the perspective of guys didn't want to
work out because they changed the
schedule I some of the most respected
trainers in the industry are on Twitter
all week now saying how can you come out
here and say you care about player
safety when you're expecting guys to
stand on the turf for 8 hours 4 p.m. to
11 verse to midnight for some of them
and like they're getting dehydrated they
can't stay loose and we're seeing the
fallout of that like Jeff Okuda didn't
do a three-cone didn't do a short
shuttle and why you know you could say
oh well he wouldn't because he's the top
prospect but man like a lot of guys
didn't work out and so the combine is
important there's a reason they do it it
does matter especially for being able to
differentiate guys CJ Henderson no three
come no short shuttle to top corners so
yeah we can divide them on film and say
a coot is better we loved to seen those
numbers at a neutral site not at you're
like Matt Bowen said not at your pro day
where they've been baking the turf and
the Sun for a year in its hardest
concrete you want these neutral site
times and man this is I don't know I
have a feeling what the NFL will do
because I don't think they actually care
I think they're gonna say this is the
way it is ratings were up our owners
want money NFL Network is owned by the
owners by the way and then you say hey
we want to keep you in that check man
so I don't think anything's gonna change
but I'll tell you there are a lot of
people very upset and I think even
really I expected this year top guys
aren't gonna go agents we'll figure
things out they'll be in there next year
now I think in the agents and trainers
are pissed off enough like we're not
gonna see Trevor Lawrence doing full
work out next year the combine there's
no way no I don't think you have to
anymore I think the most interesting one
to me Matt was T Higgins this is
somebody that was not locked into the
top 15 but really has been a player that
has been in
first round of every mock draft in a lot
of conversations the top five of this
wide receiver class he's played on a
national title team he's played in
multiple national championship games and
I think you look at it and he just said
I'm good I'm not giving you some fake
hamstring reason I'm not giving you this
I'm resting which in the polite terms is
I'm not doing the NFL Combine because
guess what I don't trust it so I think
when you look at it across the board
rightfully a lot of the top players Joe
borough chase young they said no Jeff
CUDA did you know seems to fight through
a lot of things but like you said he
also passed on some things I just think
yeah it was a very interesting year at
the combine where I always tell people
you know the week after the combine just
like the week after the draft is
actually just as busy because it's data
entry time and yesterday when I was at
home doing a lot of data entry I'm like
man there's a lot of numbers that we
still don't have and we're not gonna
have until these pro days so just to put
a bow on it it was a very unique year
for the NFL Combine yeah it is it's
funny I and I am still doubting it it's
like did nfl.com just not update the DB
times because they know one it's that
baritone yeah the cup board is empty
you're like what like what wears three
Kona short shuttle times for all the DBS
it's just no one did it none of the top
guys did it so I mean Jeff Gladney did
but and I will say it was bad and it was
bad
yes that's who six he's quicker than
that that's where I wanted to go with
that a lot and I know like agents will
make excuses yes players trainers
they're all gonna make excuses teams are
telling me we got to throw out a lot of
these times because guys were just
standing around doing nothing for hours
and then told time to your three-cone so
a lot of the times are really really
slow I mean I know rug stranded like
four to nine there's some fast 40s but
it's the agility drills where guys are
like man I was standing there for hours
doing absolutely nothing I was tight I
was ready and so I think that's why we
see you know even like the jumps there's
not a lot of great jumps this year so
it's something I feel like the combine
you almost can't historically compare a
lot of numbers from this year
why the on-field drills were super
important and that leads me into my next
point
jaelyn Hertz had an amazing week to the
point I don't know if you saw my three
grand mock draft came out Monday morning
I put him at 52 the Chicago Bears I'm
now not sure he makes it that far
Wow and the one thing that I continue to
hear about Jalen Hertz everyone says we
at least know what we're getting with
him we know he's a competitor we know
he's an athlete we know he's a winner
and you could argue quarterback wins if
you want I'm not here for it right now
but the team's know what they have in
Jalen Hertz and as one guy told me this
this week an area scout said I've
watched him get better three times I've
seen him play in the SEC I've seen him
play in that Oklahoma scheme where two
quarterbacks were just drafted first
overall in the past two years
so the Jalen Hertz profile is starting
to look really good and I'll remind you
something that we were at a dinner once
Connor with a really good scout couple
years ago and he said to us quarterback
evaluations start in January because
more than any other position it's about
what you can be not what you are and
that is going to help Jalen hurts so
much in this year's class and I think
Matt you just look on the teams on the
outside looking in on round 1 the
Chicago Bears and the Pittsburgh
Steelers I think those are my two
favorite landing spots for Jalen Hurd's
right now and how confident are we that
either of those teams are going to be
aggressive in free agency to get another
quarterback in there I don't think
they're gonna do that I think the
Steelers are obviously hoping that Big
Ben can get healthy it still seems like
a little bit of a toss up and the Bears
have also stuck by mixture Biscay so
when you look at taking a flyer in the
second round maybe like you said Matt
you have to move up now a little bit but
taking a flier on day 2 or a quarterback
that can win you more games the guy in
this class more so than Jacob Eason
right now has become Jalen Hertz yeah
it's gonna be fascinating to watch I
wouldn't be smart yea over Eason over
from would not surprise me as we get to
this point all right let's take a break
when we come back it's time to dive in a
head first to 2020 free agency teams are
gonna be spending some money when free
agency officially opens
it's a so officially opened I know that
there's other the tampering window
starts the sixteenth begun it started in
the JW Marriot one week ago it has
already started and already we're seeing
reports I think I've seen Jack Conklin
to like eight teams at this time up like
crazy man and so we're gonna do our best
to sort through some of the mud but this
is an exhaustive list and I apologize I
know this isn't always great podcasting
for us to just yell names at you guys so
we're gonna do our best to add some
context Connor let's start with the
quarterbacks and I've said it
I think anyone who covers the NFL as
like a journalist and a reporter has
said it but the Domino is Tom Brady and
until that domino falls nothing else can
happen we've seen the Julian Edelman
video we've all tried to lip read what
Brady says Vegas odds still put Brady
most likely to return to New England I
have no idea what's going to happen here
but I maintain the thing that makes the
most sense for Brady is staying in New
England where he has a chance to win
whether it's one year two years however
long he wants to play that's his best
chance to win more rings yeah it would
be a shock to me Matt if he ends up
anywhere that's not New England
I still think Vegas will make an
interesting pitcher offer to him that
wouldn't surprise me at all maybe Bruce
Arians does pick up the phone although I
still think the fit there is a little
weird but just going back to New England
is what makes the most sense for Tom
Brady
we know how Robert Kraft feels about
that I mean he will make sure that Brady
is given exactly what he needs so I just
look at this situation right now and no
matter what the rumors are with that one
I just I don't see him going anywhere
else and I know there's been some really
jarring reports but if there's any one
that I think is on the move that we've
seen in the same place for a very long
time at quarterback
I would lead more towards Phillip Rivers
yep and that's the next one Phillip
Rivers where is he gonna be is it the
Indianapolis Colts is it the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers that rumor came out when we
were at the Senior Bowl actually so I
think with rivers most signs point to
the Colts one thing I want to caution
people about Phillip Rivers I think
he'll be a
famer someday he's a fantastic player
but he was almost bench for Tyrod Taylor
this year and that's something that I
think should concern fans is if you're
the Colts is Philip Rivers better than
Jacoby perset
if you're the Buccaneers is he better
than you could probably get Teddy
Bridgewater is he better than Teddy
Bridgewater I do not think he is I think
rivers like there's a little bit of
buyer beware there I will be curious to
see if his market is low enough that he
just retires that he you know what Eli
Manning said better to go out now the me
embarrass that where's your market right
why go back out there for like 12
million dollars a year and get and get
benched it's not worth it to your legacy
so I think Rivers is interesting to
watch now the other name there Teddy
Bridgewater I have continually heard two
teams Tampa Bay and the LA Chargers now
I think the Chargers are really I feel
like that's Cam Newton where they draft
someone and I know it like I'm leaning
in more on the business side of things
than the football side of things but
that makes a ton of sense for them I
think Tampa Bay is really really
interesting for Teddy he's from Florida
we've said all along this is a guy that
needs to stay in the south because of
his lack of arm strength now he's not
your traditional Bruce Arians
quarterback though because you think of
Bruce you're like oh you must throw the
ball down the field but I was reminded
of something yesterday just making calls
trying to catch up with people
Bruce Arians tried signing drew Brees to
like a two-year 60 million dollar deal
just a couple years ago so it's not
always about arm strength if you could
throw the deep ball I think Teddy throws
a pretty good deep ball even though I
mean he's not mahomes it's not Matthew
Stafford but he has a good enough arm
and I think his deep accuracy is good
enough talking about going from Jameis
Winston who throws 30 picks in a year to
Teddy Bridgewater who does not throw
interceptions at all you couldn't find
two different quarterbacks you really
can't and I think something important to
note here Matt is not only the skill
talent that's around Teddy if he goes to
Tampa when you look at Mike Evans you
look at Chris Godwin obviously the tight
ends they have there this opens the door
for the Bucs to take an offensive tackle
in round one an area where they will
need some help especially if you sign
Teddy where you need to keep him upright
so I like that fit a lot and think for
the Bucs as much as we've over thought
it at times and said no they need a big
arm quarter
back maybe Bruce will look in a
different direction a different taste
after he's seen 30 interceptions in one
season from his quarterback I don't know
if Teddy's thrown 30 in his career
that's actually a really good question a
really good question it's worth a goo
he's thrown 25 in his career that's
amazing know he was hurt but he still
played plenty it is fascinating that
they could go from one to the other
other guys and I would consider so dak
Prescott is interesting we have to list
him as a free agent
but the Dallas Cowboys are going to do
everything they can to keep dak Prescott
he is not hitting the market he's going
to be tagged either with the franchise
or the transition tag transition tag
means any team that signs him the
Cowboys can match that if they don't
match it they would get two first-round
picks
so however they do it they're keeping
dak Prescott Connor III was even like
hesitant to put him on the list
but we have to talk about him because he
is a free agent and the Cowboys have a
ton of cap space but he has to count
against that when you think about
resigning him and yeah he's not going
anywhere
you don't let your franchise quarterback
go out the door no matter how much stuff
we've heard surrounding dak Prescott so
but the fact that he is eligible for a
free agency Matt just goes to show you
how powerful of a quarterback class this
is as a whole where even if you know the
guys not leaving the market is gonna be
set again for quarterbacks that play at
his level that are due for a big payday
yeah absolutely and on top of that Drew
Brees
going back to the Saints he has said he
wants to be back there they've said he
wants him there the only reason he's
playing in 2020 is to be with them so
that deal will get figured out Ryan
Tannehill is probably the last big-name
of the quarterbacks on the market traded
to the Titans really rejuvenated his
career there and I think that you know
talking to Mike Vrabel even at the Super
Bowl he has said it's unlikely we can
keep all the guys but it seems like
Tannehill is their second option like if
they don't get Tom Brady they're gonna
keep Ryan Tannehill again that's the
struggle with if Brady takes his time
does Ryan Tanner
go to Carolina just go to Chicago does
he go somewhere else so there's a lot of
dominoes that will come after Brady and
Tannehill is one of the biggest ones
because I look at Jameis Winston I don't
think he's gonna go somewhere and be a
sure fire starter Marcus Mariota it's
gonna be a backup chase Daniels gonna be
a backup Case Keenum is gonna be a
backup I think outside of the the guys
we've mentioned before tani Hills the
one where he's gonna go somewhere and be
a starter if it's not Tennessee Connor
what I think Carolina is the best bet
for him if it's not Tennessee and we got
to think Nick Foles is gonna get traded
that's gonna complicate things more here
but I think Tannehill I mean he's got a
couple options
I think Carolina is the ideal fit
because actually we're Tannehill
succeeds you could see it working with
Joe Brady my question is Matt and I saw
you tweet about this recently is there a
point where Carolina just throws their
hands up and say you know what we're
good this year we're gonna offload some
veterans we're gonna acquire some pics
we're not gonna draft a quarterback
we're not gonna sign one we're just
gonna ride this thing out we're gonna
lose a bunch of games and we are gonna
load up because we're gonna be the team
with Trevor Lawrence that might build a
dynasty for the future it feels that way
I mean when you know on the block and
there's timeout they I mean if you trade
Cam Newton and Trey Turner you got a
couple young tackles and DJ Moore and
Christian McCaffrey obviously but yeah i
think i think carolina makes sense and
on that you know if you're trying to
tank for trevor
ryan tannenhill that might actually be
too good for you but you might just hey
we have Kyle Allen we have a little
Greer let's see what they can do it it
will be they are a very interesting team
and I think Tennessee
you know we're talk about Ryan Tannehill
let's just go to the running backs here
Derek Henry I personally do not know
what you do with this guy may over the
last year and a half you could say he
was the best running back in football
but yeah you pay a running back and I
thank you every example of running backs
in the NFL right now you don't do it you
don't pay these guys a second contract
and with the CBA I don't want to get too
deep into the weeds on this but if a new
C a B CBA is
nine teams could be in a situation where
you can only use the franchise or
transition tag you can't use both well
if they use the tag to keep Tannehill
Derek Henry she's gonna hit the market
and we saw last year Melvin Gordon let
me on Belle those guys didn't have the
market they expected
I could see Derek Henry back in
Tennessee on like a three-year deal that
pays him like 12 million dollars a year
the problem is he has said he wants Zeke
Elliott money I do not have that right
it's not happening so I'll say this Matt
a fit that makes sense for him but I
don't know if it goes with our friend
Brandon beans velocity philosophy is the
bills a little bit because motor
Singletary was a really really nice
draft pick Josh Allen is not a guy you
want dropping back and throwing the ball
40 times a game right if you have this
tandem of Derrick Henry motor Singletary
Josh Allen's mobility you draft a big
wide receiver that's an offense that's
very interesting to me maybe it's a
little like Tennessee's offense so I
just don't know and the Bills have a ton
of cap space they have over 82 million
dollars and they haven't even cut anyone
yet so when you and they got to get a
pass rusher up there and Buffalo as well
but they got money to spend so Derrick
Henry if it's not the Titans the fit I
like I just don't know if they believe
in paying a running back like that would
be Buffalo yeah and I think Baltimore
makes sense but you have Mark Ingram so
yeah that's the problems like teams that
want to run the ball and I think you
could say it's about Derrick Henry
except about Melvin Gordon there's not a
lot of fits that just makes sense for
them there's not a lot of teams that
really need a running back like oh the
Miami Dolphins gonna pay for a running
back when they have five picks in the
top two rounds and they're expected to
have 13 picks in the entire draft it's
hard to slot these guys in whether it's
Henry I mean Melvin Gordon was
first-round pick he's a really good
running back he tried holding out last
year and it just did not work and that's
one thing I have a hard time with when I
look at these running backs is where do
i slaughter in it because this is a good
running back draft class by the way so
if you could have Melvin Gordon like I
mean just Melvin Gordon go to the
Steelers where James Connor hasn't been
great I like that fit
I think this is a team that is trying to
win now I meet the trades they've made
trading up to you Devin Bush trading get
minka I can see the Steelers being a fit
for Gordon but again it's not gonna be a
15 million a year I think the problem is
Matt you have the sample size of running
backs that got paid and it's failed
miserably you look at Devon so Freeman
you look at Todd Gurley you look at I
mean I think levian was a mix of maybe
he's not the same levy on but the Jets
were just a miserable offensive team
especially the line but the point is all
of the running backs that got mega
contracts and we'll see how Zeke ages I
thought this year was good but once
again that was not a one-year deal that
was a mega deal there's a sample size
there we're paying running backs a big
second deal has not worked in the favor
of the teams right so all right well
moving on I'm not a good running back
man it's just no the Melvin Gordon is
another one is a complete wildcard I
don't think he gets a very good payday
that he wanted Lamar Miller is coming
off season-ending injury he's been a
very productive running back throughout
his career but once again if you're
coming off injury and you play that
position at his age creeping up towards
30 don't think he gets anything crazy
the one name I'm very interested in and
I think he needs to go back to Arizona
is Kenyan Drake
I am absolutely with you watching him
play second half of the season was so
much fun in that offense he fits exactly
what they need David Johnson's contract
is a mess I think they're still gonna
try to figure out a way to move him I
would keep Kenyan Drake up I mean they
traded draft picks to get him midseason
I think the test drive was phenomenal he
is such a seamless fit there so I keep
Kenyan Drake you mention amar Miller
another guy whose run for the Houston
Texans Carlos Hyde Carlos Hyde had the
quietest thousand-yard season I've ever
seen I have he's a free agent Payton
barbers a free agent I think he'll
probably get pushed out in Tampa because
Ronald Jones actually finish the you're
fairly well to running back position now
I want to get like a little bit will be
a little bit of a Homer here your team
the New York Jets levy on bells coming
back we're gonna hope they use him right
Melo's team the Chiefs they're always
looking to add guys and then the Niners
who have like five running backs right
now of the three teams that we follow
closest on this podcast I feel like like
if Kenyan Drake got loose and was
willing to just take a pay cut to win a
ring he would make so much sense in
Kansas City but they are so up against
the cap they really can't afford to pay
anyone a good amount at that position
no he's the perfect fit there though and
that kind of makes you wonder Matt can
they find a Kenyan Drake on day three of
the draft and something that you've been
telling Chiefs fans and now I just relay
the message on Twitter is don't expect
Jonathan Taylor in the first round don't
you know what I'm he and don't expect
the Andre Swift in the first round you
need to be looking at the guys like
maybe Anthony McFarland is somebody that
they're interested maybe Darren's in
heaven so maybe players like that
Keyshawn Vaughn those guys that are
probably going around four or five or
six that makes a lot of sense for Kansas
City just to wrap up such a great point
you make about Carlos Hyde having a
quiet thousand yards he averaged 4.4
yards of carry this year accounted for a
1.9 million dollar cap hit Ezekiel
Elliott County had 4.5 yards of carry
and hovers around that 10 to 16 million
dollars a year and I'm not saying
anything cuz I know it's just the stat
yards per carry but man when you're in a
good run scheme you can get something
out of nobodies you really can it's
unbelievable when you watch just how
that works and it kind of wraps up our
fridge and running back conversation
here is is anyone gonna pay these guys
because I don't think so
well we know someone will be paying
these guys let's get to the offensive
line before we take a break and come
back for the pass catchers Jack Conklin
is the belle of the ball your New York
Jets have been linked to him but you're
your initial take away there well I'll
say this there is no doubt that New York
Jets are interested in signing Jack
Conklin I think they have the money to
pay him as the top tackle in football
which is something they'll probably have
to do I know people don't love hearing
that but guess what that is the game
that is free agency especially for a
team that let's be real is a little
desperate right now in the offensive
lines so I think when you look at Jack
Conklin you said it Matt it's the fact
that he plays tackle he's going to have
a lot of teams putting out offers for
him I'm curious if the Browns get
involved here I
pro football talk reported that it's
expected the Jets land Jack Conklin Adam
Schefter countered with that it's
expected they don't all you need to know
is he's represented by rosenhouse sports
they know a thing or two about leverage
their driving this price up but I do
think Joe Douglas is the guy that comes
out in day one and offers him the most
money the question is does Jack Conklin
want to spend the prime of his career
now protecting Sam Darnell that's what
everyone's really wondering here do the
engine does the injury history concern
you if he's dead yeah go ahead I mean
he's he's gonna get a ton of guaranteed
money so of course it concerns you
that's what bothers me all pros are
rookie and then injuries kind of took
their toll in this past year bounced
back and played it an exceptionally high
level so I think that's whether you're
the Jets the Giants I mean this guy has
been linked to every team that has money
basically at this point which goes to
show just how talented he is of a player
but I would be a little bit worried
about a guy who two of his four years
have been pretty banged up and to the
point that the Titans didn't pick up his
fifth your option which is why he's an
unrestricted free agent now another
player on the interior who's gonna set
the market is Joe Tunney the New England
Patriots I think they would love to keep
him but they just don't do that they
don't keep guys and they have a ton of
the agents to sign and they don't have a
lot of money which is I know we talk
about this so much it's fascinating I do
not know where their money goes but they
don't have a lot of it it doesn't seem
like foon he's the kind of guy that
they're gonna keep I mean they would
rather get the third-round comp pick
then keep it know if he's smart he gets
to the open market I mean the way he
moves Matt he can flourish in any kind
of zone scheme I'm really impressed with
Rooney no penalties this year which is
another impressive stat he's a great run
blocker he's been reliable in past
protection I'm very curious to see you
know what direction he goes in the bills
are a team that they're gonna be losing
a guard and Quinton Spain if they opted
not to bring him back
I thought Spain played pretty well this
year but did they'd go for the upgrade
and thew knee once again the New York
Jets Joe Douglas is gonna open the
checkbook he's not gonna land Conklin
and thew knee but if you can get one of
those guys step in the right direction
for a miserable offensive line unit in
front of your 22 year old quarterback
the New York Giants are a team that I
think they'll be more aggressive in the
tackle market but once again we've
talked about how much the Cardinals need
to look at offensive line I do think
that'll be in the top ten of the draft
but there are a lot of different teams
here
that have a lot of money including the
Denver Broncos as well where these two
guys at the top of this four agency
class at offensive line and Conklin and
Dooney they are going to get paid oh
absolutely
I mean the salary cap just keeps going
up and so guys like that are getting
Brandon Scherff if not tagged it's going
to get paid I even think Andres Pete
will get paid I mean that there's just
there's cash to burn it's hard to draft
offensive linemen so you go for the
shore thing and I even think so the
secondary market Anthony Costanzo Brian
bulaga Jason Peters is 38 years old I
wouldn't be surprised if he just decides
to retire but I mean we've seen Andrew
Whitworth have a nice little second half
of his career with the LA Rams there's a
lot of players out there who Graham
Glascow Quinton Spain guys who can be
good starters but do you think our good
friend Eric flowers get signed I will
say yes he actually didn't have a
terrible year last oh he was a decent
guard
not a horrible guard so I do think he
gets signed at a minimum he's a backup
but he starts Matt I know I'll tell you
what team that's just looking for a guy
that is a decent run blocker uh maybe
maybe he starts again next year um you
know there's some really interesting
names we think Brandon chefs gonna get
franchised Trey Turner I think is a
really good player and I'm actually a
little surprised about here in the trade
rumors or release rumors one of the most
fascinating ones has to be Andres Pete
right I mean you look at how that Saints
line is played you look at his injury
history it feels like another version of
Jack Conklin where you're taking a risk
but you could get a really big reward if
it pans out yeah I think Pete is a
really really good player again like you
said you just the only thing you worry
about is injuries I mean he did not this
past year was not good but it was
because he was banged up and you know
missed like five or six games right
there in the middle of the season but I
go back and look at you know what he's
been at other points in his career he's
a he's a better pass blocker than he has
run blocker that was the knock on him
coming out of school as well when he was
coming out of Stanford but I think with
everybody going to almost everyone's
gonna be running zone next year I think
someone like Andres Pete makes a lot of
sense
all right the fun positions are up next
wide receivers and tight ends we'll be
back right after this
you guys know this is a historic wide
receiver draft there's it's like 45
receivers with a draftable grade but
it's also a pretty good wide receiver
class when it comes to free agency the
top guy Conner Amari Cooper again with a
cba we're waiting to see what happens if
the Cowboys can actually tag him and dak
Prescott but it feels like he wants to
be back they want him back so I think
Amari Cooper most likely back to Dallas
which then for me would put AJ Green
near the top of this receiver class even
though you know I think he's 30 years
old and he's been hurt 31 31 and has
been hurt that's terrifying but still
it's AJ green and it sounds like he
might get tagged as well Matt I have a
hot take on this situation there's a
rapport and now I guess I'm assuming
it's true but you should assume it's
true it seems reliable that Joe burrow
made it clear he wants the Bengals to
keep AJ Green I don't think AJ green
plays on the tag for whatever it's worth
he's gonna be 32 in July with all his
injuries I think he wants that one more
three-year deal not the one-year money I
actually think it's a bad decision by
Joe burrow to ask for the Bengals to
keep AJ green because the Bengals don't
always spend a lot of money and you need
to be kind of smart with your request of
where your assets are going I don't know
if a 32 year old injured AJ Green is
worth 15 plus million on the cap anymore
a guy who do my crazy wait no you're not
crazy he didn't play last year so I
don't know yeah I like Tyler Boyd I
think they're I would rather be 233 and
use that money on a linebacker which we
will get to in the next segment when we
talk about linebackers so yeah I'm not
real high on AJ green but I'm with you I
think if he's back it's proud
because Joe burrow said hey I want an
established receiver in there your guy
Robbie Anderson I think the best pure
slot receiver who's available in free
agency he's going to find a good amount
of money in a new home I think somewhere
else I just it doesn't feel like Joe
Ellis is gonna prioritize this position
or keeping Robbie Anderson at least
seems like he's gonna be on the move
yeah everything I've heard with this is
that they did not plan to to really make
a significant push before free agency
hit which in return Robbie Anderson said
okay I'll hit the market it seemed like
the Jets were playing the lowball game I
think they didn't want to go a lot of
years on the deal is what I understand
with that and Matt I mean the guy's got
speed to win on the inside to win on the
outside they use them in motion that's
valuable in the league right now the
thing that I'm not understanding with
the Jets is when this new CBA agreement
goes through that cap is kind of spiked
they should have got this deal done and
now I think it's gonna be somebody
else's reward I'm curious to watch the
Raiders here I'm curious to watch if the
Ravens just want to load up on speed and
say hey we got Hollywood Brown and we'll
use Robbie on the outside we've sending
those guys deep we got Lamar Jackson and
really good tight ends and really good
backs so I think Robbie Anderson does
get his 13 million per year that he's
asking for Matt yeah that's what I was
thinking about like places that make
sense for him
I mean if Seattle wants to add another
weapon something I've heard they want to
add another weapon with dk and Tyler
Lockett they have money this year which
they normally don't so there are a lot
of teams that would want what Robbie
Aaron do some Anderson brings to the
table now low key free agent Emmanuel
Sanders the Niners trader for this guy
and now he's a free agent I think they
would like to keep him but the Niners
have no money and they also have I mean
Ark Armstead Jimmy Ward our free agents
so they have some pretty big free agents
they got to try to keep Emmanuel Sanders
is another one where he played pretty
well and like made a lot of tough
catches over the middle if you were a
team like New England Emanuel Sanders
Robbie Anderson like Nelson a galore
it's those are the kind of guys that I
would think the Patriots would try to go
get if they keep Tom Brady
they're not the greatest but they're at
least plug and play type receivers
without a doubt I'm curious to see what
they do here I know a lot of Niners fans
understandably want Emmanuel Sanders
back as they should but the what you
know the question is what kind of kappa
is he gonna be looking at here and then
you'd look across the board there are
plenty of teams that need veteran
receivers I think you bring up a good
point Matt that if the Patriots do bring
back Tom Brady they're gonna have to do
it with some better weapons for him now
you like that Nikhil Harry's gonna be
healthy you obviously have Edelman there
they'll need to attack tight end but I
don't think they would be done at wide
receiver so I also look at a team you
know what are the Eagles gonna do at
wide receiver they have to be aggressive
they're another team for Robbie Anderson
they've tried to trade for him before I
believe they offered a fourth round pick
to the Jets and the Jets said no thanks
so I think the Eagles are a team that
comes out in free agency and says hey we
got to add a body here at the wide
receiver position we can't rely on al
Sean Jeffery we know Nelson Aguilar sent
in free agency we can't just go into the
draft looking to reef planets this group
we need to sign someone and I would
throw in there in that same that's a
mindset the bills who have 83 million
dollars in caps playing without a doubt
feed badly the Redskins have 62 million
and some of that could go to Brandon
Scherff but that's another team like
Terry Clarence the dude they actually
need some depth at wide receiver so I
think those are two teams in the top ten
in terms of cap space then make some
sense for these receivers now let's move
to the tight ends there are other
receivers Devin Funchess Taylor Gabriel
Randall Cobb those guys aren't really
doing anything for me as far as free
agency goes feel free to jump in if they
move the needle for you well I look when
I look at the tight ends its Hunter
Henry and it's Austin Hooper and both
could be tagged Hunter Henry another
player very injury riddled career with
Chargers but exceptional when he's on
the field
Austin Hooper with the Packers excuse me
what the Falcons could be tagged if not
we like him maybe to go to Green Bay
Connor where that is out I think you you
said it Matt at the combine you had
heard tons of buzz the Packers were
doing their work on the tight end class
doing their work on not just the draft
class but also the free agent group a
Green Bay as a team that in the mr. G
era
they've thrown some money out and fridge
see Matt I'd like the new direction the
Packers have gone they've looked to sign
edge pass rushers they've looked to help
out their offense a little bit so I
think for Green Bay you know Austin
Hooper coming off a season where he had
75 catches almost eight hundred yards
and six touchdowns I really like the fit
for Green Bay there and think it's a
weapon that would help Aaron Rodgers in
the middle of the field I kind of one
thing we've been saying I damage saying
this for like three months but if hunter
hunter Henry is not tagged I think he
becomes a New England Patriot I think
they would throw big money at him he
fits everything they want and one thing
we've said a lot is this is a historic
wide receiver class so the free agents
might not get paid outside of Amari
Cooper it is not a great tight end class
there's not gonna be maybe Cole commits
goes in round one but not a lot of
top-tier tight ends especially coming
out of the combine where a lot of the
guys disappointed
so hunter Henry if he gets loose from
the Chargers is gonna see pretty big
money I think so - I think it's once
again the whole you know supply and
demand thing that where plenty of teams
are looking to have a tight end is maybe
not the focal point of their offense but
maybe as the number 2 or number 3 weapon
and there's just not a ton of talent out
there that was one of my big thoughts
coming out of the compound this week and
I don't know if you felt the same I look
at this tight end class and I go man
you're not betting on it I'll tell you
that I like Cole commit I think he's a
really nice seam in red zone target and
can block but that's one guy I don't
think hunter Bryant is the athlete I was
hoping he was he's still a good pass
catcher but I don't think he's this you
know elite option this round 1 or maybe
not even top 50 kind of option and for
the guy that had the best week of any of
them mr. Alberto running that for for
940 he had trouble staying on the field
in college so this the point is the free
agent class at tight end highlighted by
Hunter Henry in Austin Hooper those guys
should get the bag real soon
absolutely all right let's take a break
when we come back defense and there is a
lot of it oh yeah it is a defense heavy
free agent class if none of those names
in the first two segments did it for you
these names will Connor let's just start
with the edge rushers Yannick and gaku I
said hey you can tag me I'm not coming
back
Jadeveon Clowney the seahawks promise
not to tag him when they traded for him
you got former first rounders I mean
Dante Fowler Vic Beasley Robert yeah
Quinn Shack Lawson there's big names and
actually some pretty good players guys
who we think could be instant impacts
let's start with Yannick and Gok wave he
does not go back to the Jacksonville
Jaguars I'm looking at the team and the
NFL who has the most salary cap space at
a whopping ninety three point seven
million dollars in a gigantic need for a
pass rusher that is the Miami Dolphins
who like we said earlier they have five
picks in the first two rounds of this
draft if they can land Yannick and Gok
way in free agency and not have to trade
for a pass rusher oh my god this is
amazing for them I think the only
problem is Matt they're probably gonna
have to trade for a franchise tag beyond
I think I'm dreaming here no but I like
that the point of frig-in shows is to
give everyone the most hope possible and
I will challenge the listeners I
guarantee we mentioned your football
team at least once in this show and if
you gotta prove me wrong if you think we
didn't but back to this I'm looking at
this Matt Yannick and gaku a gets tagged
we see a trade maybe somewhat similar to
Frank Clark because you're gonna have to
pay the guy almost 20 million dollars a
year right how about that 26th overall
pick in the draft for Yannick and Gok
way from the Miami Dolphins is that
something you do for each side without a
doubt I would and I think the Dolphins
we're gonna connect them to a lot of
players with that potential because they
they have those two second-round errs
they pick again at 39 they have picked
56 so I think there will be a lot of
conversation about what can we get for
the 26th pick overall Yannick and Gok
way is better than probably any prospect
you're gonna get you would you know
we're just getting a 25 year old pass
rusher who not only is he great at
getting to the quarterback
I think he's like fourth in the NFL on
strip sacks since he's been drafted so
an exceptional player if you don't get
Yannick and Gok way another guy who
could be tagged is matt jude on so we
can see a tag and trade the ravens now
the asking price is not gonna be close
to the same i think it's maybe a
second-round pick maybe a package of a
third plus but Maju Don who really broke
out this pasture for the ball
more Ravens again a guy who I think he
would fit the Dolphins I think he would
fit the Lions exceptionally well if they
have money to spend
opposite Trey flowers you're getting
someone who has no power to his game
he's a big pass rusher and how about
this one the Buffalo Bills have 83
million dollars very very quietly they
have a lot of money if you don't bring
back Shaq Lawson doesn't Matt Joe Don
feel like an upgrade that you can just
swap out the salaries for I think so I
really do I think with the bills they
need something on the edge I think
they'd like to bring back Shaq but I
would be a little bit more aggressive I
don't know if they're gonna make the
trade for someone like Yannick but when
you look at Jude on that's one that
makes sense Matt because I do agree
that's more of a day to pick not a
first-round kind of pick the Bills have
a ton of money but they do have some
very interesting free agents you have
Shaq Lawson you have Jordan Phillips you
have Quinton Spain so they have plenty
to they have plenty of money to spend
here but I think that at the same time
they do have some of their own to take
care of I'm fascinated to see if they're
really really aggressive attacking
upgrades at the edge spot yeah in Geneva
clowny let's just roll right into that
sure ghost goes to Seattle from the
Houston Texans the Seahawks need him
they want him back I think there's a
good chance that clowny is just signed
to an extension it's a little concerning
it hasn't happened yet but I think this
will get figured out if he is allowed to
leave I think there are a lot of timing
every team's gonna want this guy the
Giants the Colts the Dolphins there's me
a long list of teams that would want
Jadeveon Clowney but you do have to
worry about a player who hasn't been
very healthy over the course of his
career I think there's a
better-than-average chance he just goes
back to the Seahawks if he wants to win
that makes the most sense I'm with you
it's where he's had the most success he
looked really really consistent there I
like the fit and once again like you
said Matt that's a team that wins
someone else that I find fascinating
coming off of a career year Dante Fowler
had 11 and a half sacks last year I know
it was not the best year for the Rams
I know Fowler had like any other human
would has benefited playing on the same
front with Aaron Donald but I think the
point is at 25 years old and ascending
now with Fowler
I think he's actually gonna get a decent
contract here I think he's somebody that
you know once again maybe the Colts the
Jets the Giants teams that have a
serious free agent need a pass rusher if
they miss the boat on the tag guys and
gawk way jus daun every single fan goes
back to Minnesota
clowny goes back to Seattle I'm really
curious how the Fowler market starts to
take shape yeah and I I don't want to
make this all about our favorite teams
but your team the New York Jets makes a
lot of sense for one of these guys
they're gonna spend money right they
have a lot of money they're gonna spend
it at 11 overall you're not able to
draft a premier pass rusher I would say
the same thing about the Indianapolis
Colts at where that 12 overall you're
not gonna excuse me 13 overall you're
not getting a premier pass rusher in
this draft most likely so the Jets the
Colts the Bucs most likely gonna tag
Shaq Barrett who's being listed as a
linebacker the Falcons who Vic Beasley
is afraid Junt Vic Beasley has had like
two good years two bad years so I think
the Falcons are a team that could be
looking to bring in someone as a pass
rusher so a lot of names that we're
gonna throw to place I ever seen Griffin
I think stays with the Vikings they've
kind of said they want him back I think
he wants to come back so then you get to
the like I would almost call it like
tier like Robert Quinn is probably still
tier two
but Jordan Jenkins I mean is he a strong
side linebacker is the ad end the Jets
used him in a couple different ways I
think there will be a small market for
him maybe ream like the Saints for
Jordan Jenkins would make some sense
just I'm just thinking in terms of usage
well I mean you guys know I say the
salary cap is fake but I mean it's like
the speed limit it's a guideline the
Saints don't have a ton of money to
spend we'll see what happens with Drew
Brees contract if it allows some
flexibility but when you look at the
pass rushers I mean there's some really
good ones and I'll throw this out there
the Patriots are gonna lose a lot of
free agents we've seen them in the past
there was one year they signed to 18
free agents they're gonna find a lot of
guys low love like Vic Beasley going to
New England on like a one-year pruvit
deal would be so smart for him to get
into a system where they're actually
pretty good at rehabilitating guys
completely they love doing that because
they know they can get the most out of
those players and at
when you go back to Jordan Jenkins will
see how the Shaq Barrett situation
shakes out but wouldn't be surprised you
know Bucks have a lot of cap space maybe
Todd Bowles a guy that drafted him
brings him in there so the edge market
is unlike the draft is actually pretty
dense in free agency it's exciting and I
think another group just the segment
right into it is the defensive tackle
group Matt yes highlighted by a player
you know very well in Chris Jones yeah
Chris Jones the Chiefs already said
they're gonna give him the tag as soon
as that window opens we've discussed a
lot the Chris Jones makes sense the
Kansas City Chiefs want to keep this man
they've made contract offers in the past
to keep him it's just a matter of now
where do you best allocate your
resources because you have Patrick
mahomes you can win multiple Super Bowls
with this player but you do have to
surround him with some talent I know
folks in Kansas City even on the
coaching staff who will say the best
Frank Clark has Chris Jones beside him
they are their production works very
well in tandem so I think with Chris
Jones they would like to keep him and I
could see a situation I know we talked
about this from the combine where he
plays out 2020 under the tag and then
they let him walk or they trade him to a
team like the Miami Dolphins like the
Seattle Seahawks teams that have picks
and they have the cap to burn now
another guy O'Connor who was traded from
your team litter Williams is a free
agent
the Giants trade for him and their
compensation to the Jets hinges on
whether or not he signed long term Dave
gentlemen the GM has come out and said
listen if I don't keep this guy I'll
basically be burned at the stake but let
me wave does make sense for if you're
running a three-four defense hello
Denver Broncos litter wavers makes a lot
of sense for you that's just who he is
it's just a matter of that you know the
Giants are they able to keep a guy they
trade it for I was gonna say a team we
have not talked about that has a lot of
cap spaces the Denver Broncos and I
think they can get involved in this
defensive line group I think listen are
the Chiefs gonna move Chris Jones the
Denver absolutely not but then you get
into the next year whether it's Leonard
Williams Shabat Hargrave DJ reader
Jordan Phillips there's a lot of
different names here that the Broncos
can attack to help up front and I'm
curious to see how it plays out because
Dave gentlemen
as shown his hand a little bit and said
you know we want to keep this guy the
Jets get a third rounder this year no
matter what but if the Giants do extend
him before free agency that 2021 fifth
rounder becomes a fourth rounder so the
cost to keep Leonard Williams does go up
even when not factoring the money yeah
it absolutely does and let's move to
another team that we know very well the
San Francisco 49ers have very little cap
space Arik Armstead just had the best
year of his life playing this new
defensive scheme the way they've used
him up front and he could get paid I
know there's interest in San Francisco
they want to keep him they don't want to
let him go Arik Armstead
I mean think it has a very good chance
to get paid you just mentioned Denver
they run a three-four defense Vic Fangio
would know how to use Arik Armstead the
Houston Texans I mean they have JJ Watt
they have Charleston many who I think
they want to invest on the defensive
line the Washington Redskins excuse me
now watch Tyrell Seahawks would like to
invest in the defensive line we've seen
before in the NFC West especially teams
like to steal from each other those are
all clubs that have top-ten cap space
that I think you have to be interested
in and Arik Armstead who just again had
a fantastic season
I would throw the Colts in there as
another team that would understand how
to use him as a versatile piece whether
he's playing defensive in his play nose
tackle whether he plays three tech he
plays all over the d line so the Arik
Armstead compared to another guy like a
Michael Brokers I think Armstead is
gonna have a much much bigger market
than AB rockers or a Derek Wolfe other
guys who have played in a 3-4 scheme I
think so too and I'm fascinated by the
bottom of this market because it goes to
show you how deep it is with veteran
talent Matt when you have Gerald McCoy
you haven't dhama can sue you talked
about Brock errs there's damon harrison
derrick wolf who you talked about as
well we'll see what Jordan Phillips gets
I think this is a situation where a team
like the Dallas Cowboys that might be
looking at not necessarily the bargain
bin but they're gonna have to be cost
effective after they get the dak
extension done after they get Amari
Cooper back I think Byron Jones will
price himself out we're gonna talk about
him in a little bit I think this is a
really good opportunity for the Dallas
Cowboys to swoop in and improve that
defensive line with the tier 3 free
agents that you know can give you above
average starting play
for an entire season absolutely like we
were saying the Patriots like be smart
like go sign your guy sign you're free
agents to low-level deals that you know
what they can be Jeremiah is not gonna
play 75 snaps a game but he could play
25 and have a pretty big impact so I
think we'll see that happen let's move
to the linebacker market it is led by
Joe Schobert
the Browns are not keeping him which
surprises me
it feels like the Oakland Raider excuse
me Las Vegas Raiders and Green Bay
Packers should be all over Joe Schobert
as a linebacker who is perfect for what
they do defensively it feels like that I
mean he's gonna have no shortage of a
market once he gets out there I don't
think so at all I think yeah I'm with
you I think there won't be any shortage
there when Schobert it's kind of crazy
but Matt he's probably priced himself in
a 10 million dollar per year linebacker
right if not more yeah I really think so
I mean same with Corey Littleton who I
think two years ago a lot of fans had no
idea who Corey Littleton is yup he's
probably gonna get 12 or 13 million
dollars a year again by the Packers or
by by the Raiders you know one of those
teams that we talk about all the time
like oh they need a middle linebacker
and those guys are perfect fit so I
think that yeah there's gonna be a huge
market for players like that and I think
you know we've talked a lot about the
Broncos I wouldn't be shocked if they
get in this market when it comes to
linebackers I wouldn't be shocked if the
Patriots do they're gonna lose Kyle van
Noy most likely so the Saints could use
a linebacker I think by picked 24 in the
draft you're kind of worried a guy like
that would be around the Ravens could
use a linebacker they traditionally
don't sign players they draft them but
man they there could be a lot of
movement between Schobert and Littleton
and Nick quick quick Kowski who could
really really affect not only the market
but the draft - yeah and we're gonna see
a bit of a Swiss Army knife type player
Kyle van Noy how is he valued I mean you
talk about a a rough start I think in
Detroit I think he really rebounded his
career and became a very good player for
a New England and the question is is New
England interested in bringing him back
what kind of discount will he take if he
does or really just test the market and
go to the highest bidder so you're
getting a consistent theme here if
you've listened to this show this
defensive group is not only has start
allant at the top of every position
but it's got starting talent across the
board sometimes eight to ten deep yeah
it absolutely does and Shaq Barrett
probably gonna get tagged us an outside
linebacker bug Dupree probably gonna get
tagged as an outside linebacker so those
are two other names were Shaq Barrett
has had a historic season and outside
linebacker I think he's gonna want to
stay with Todd Bowles how about the DBS
and we've a couple teams we haven't
talked about this is why because we were
waiting to get to the DB portion oh yes
Minnesota Vikings fans perk up your ears
here because we've been waiting for you
here's a huge one Byron Jones is gonna
leave the Dallas Cowboys they just can't
afford to pay everyone I've heard it all
week at the combine he's gonna go to the
east coast whether it's your jets the
nearer Giants the Philadelphia Eagles
Byron Jones is most likely going
northeast James Bradbury with the
Carolina Panthers probably goes wherever
Byron Jones doesn't so I think Byron
Jones is like that the cornerback
dominoe James Bradbury if he leaves
Carolina is gonna have a big big market
as well man if you're the New York
Giants this is the guy you go get you're
rebuilding that defense you need a
veteran presence on the back end in that
secondary and this is a double whammy if
you're the New York Giants you are
making the Cowboys worse you are getting
better Byron Jones is a top five corner
when he is healthy he is a great athlete
he is a smart player he can handle a lot
of different roles
the Giants showed signs of life of
getting it right on offense last year
and I think they're gonna improve that
group around Daniel Jones through the
draft but when you look at this defense
they do have a lot of holes they have a
lot of young players they're trying to
develop that secondary though it needs a
staple it needs a foundational piece
that can be the guy for the next three
years and Byron Jones he's worth that 18
million dollar price tag for them for
the New York Giants they should come out
day one and Dave gentlemen should get
this signing done I absolutely agree and
then the judge should probably sign
James Bradbury and you guys can just
have a joint press conference at MetLife
and just call it a day Chris Harris jr.
all-pro tslot corner
he has met I saw rapport he's met with
20 teams or his agents have met with 20
teams so Chris Harris juniors gonna have
a big big market I know you've thought
about the Dallas Cowboys make a ton of
sense for him
the Chiefs do as well but salary cap
concerns are gonna be a huge problem
there and I think the Atlanta Falcons
are a team that they make sense for a
lot of these guys Chris Harris jr. Jimmy
Ward
Logan Ryan they've drafted a lot of
corners but they still need a corner
especially with Desmond Trufant getting
older the Falcons just don't have money
they're projected right now to have the
third least amount of money in the NFL
with only the Vikings and Steelers ahead
of them so they would have to be
creative to make this happen
it ought to free move to have to be cut
but I think those players Chris Harris
jr. Jimmy Ward Logan Ryan would be the
players that you would want there and
this leaves to me a really interesting
safety class and then we have a lot of
guys who were like first-round picks
that haven't lived up to it but at the
safety position Anthony Harris Vikings
gotta find a way to keep this guy me
he's the league no one talks about Tony
Jefferson was cut he's unfortunately
injured right now he's gonna be healthy
in and probably May so I think he will
have a slow market and then damarious
Randall is a free agent who if you just
let him play free safety he's a pretty
damn good one
the Niners if Jimmy Ward leaves I think
damarious Randall makes a lot of sense
it's kind of a lower budget type safety
he could be in Dallas he was with Mike
McCarthy and Green Bay so I think these
guys are all gonna have a good market
but Anthony Harris is the belle of the
ball when it comes to the safeties yeah
and I think you bring up a great point
about the Vikings
I know Vikings fans you're listening to
the show and you said why didn't you
mention us with Joe Thune II why didn't
you get us involved in that offensive
line class they got to clear up some cap
space there are some contracts here and
there but you need to remember even if
you clear eight to ten million there you
need to allocate that cap money to your
draft class now so and you got to take
care of your own guy and Anthony Harris
so I think the Vikings they have an ease
at corner at outside corner the Xavier
roads days those best days are behind
they probably have to get creative in
the giraffe to fill that spot Matt so
for the Vikings clear up some cap bring
back your own but you're it's a great
roster
when you have a great roster
unfortunately you have a lot of salary
cap space because great rosters need to
make money and this is a team that will
continue will have to continue to hit it
out of the park in the draft yeah to
other teams I want to talk about here I
can't remember if we hit them but they
make a lot of sense for a safety
position the Chicago Bears the LA Rams I
think both could use a free safety
neither have much money and so I think
they're gonna have to be really smart
about where the money goes especially if
the Bears have a decently priced backup
quarterback on the roster that's gonna
chew up a ton of space that you would
spend on damarious Randall or an Anthony
Harris or you know even when we get into
the market a little bit below that I
mean it's just Sean Davis I mean can you
can even get a Sean Davis so it's gonna
be tough for those teams that definitely
have a need at safety and I think the
the Bears have a need at corner with
Prince Amukamara going elsewhere so I
mean but you're looking at like a bashad
Breeland who had a hell of a postseason
for the chance our or and this is where
the show ends today you get to the
former first rounders who are now free
agents because I haven't lived up to the
hype Bradley Roby Ronald Darby
Eli Apple Verna Hargreaves Rd burns all
free agents that sounds like a club
you'd see in a gridiron heights episode
but I think when you look at the Bears
the question they're gonna have is they
just dumped a ton of money rightfully so
into Eddie Jackson are they gonna spend
at the other safety spot mat or are they
gonna look to Draft at the safety spot
on you know probably day three to be
completely honest with you but corner
market like you said this is probably
where the Bears come in maybe you take a
swing at one of those former first
rounders and try to get the best of him
to supplement your corner group there in
Chicago but man that was a lot to go
through and I feel pretty good about it
I think we hit it pretty hard and we're
gonna do this again next week or in like
13 days two weeks that's how long that
is when we recap it all we're gonna we
were wrong about everything
and I think right before free agency
we're gonna look more team by team I
think that would be all three of us on
the on a show yet looking at okay this
is what these teams need and honestly
we'll probably we're talking out loud or
like thinking out loud here just each
take like eight teams or how many ever
have twelve
teams and really dig in on those teams
because there's a lot that happens to
free agency and again this sets the
table for the draft because it teams
make a splash it you know Byron Jones
goes to the Giants we can we don't worry
about Jeff Okuda there you know if
firing Jones goes to the Jets we're not
thinking CJ Henderson there if Jack
Conklin goes to the Jets we might not be
thinking offensive tackle as early as we
had in the past so although we still
might I would I would say I said it that
was a good would I would yeah if you can
get me Trista wharfs and Jack Conklin
beautiful bed not bad for Sammy D
absolutely we will be back Friday
morning me Connor and Melo check us out
on Bleacher Report's YouTube page
there's actually a playlist called stick
to football you can subscribe to it find
all the shows there and of course the
podcast version apple podcast Spotify
stitcher wherever you get your shows
check that out thank you guys again
we'll talk to you real soon